inflation isn't experienced by everyone
at the same rate of course
so coming out of the 2008 2009 crisis
there was a bunch of studies done that
show the bottom
40 percent of americans experience
somewhere between six to ten percent
inflation levels
which is higher than where we are today
right obviously
but the top didn't experience six to ten
percent yeah but the difference is that
the people who make the decisions are at
the top
and so what they do is they look around
and they say oh inflation's not that bad
and when you look at the blended
it may seem like it's lower but the most
vulnerable people in our society
experience the highest levels of
inflation yeah the people that are the
percentage of their monthly
uh uh costs or expenses end up being in
the highest
number of inflationary goods grocery
stations all housing
so when you ask that question i'm
willing to bet right now if you're the
bottom 20
of americans your inflation rate's over
10 percent yeah easily
scary right i mean just think about that
for a second
even if it's only 10.5 percent if you're
in the bottom 20
of americans you probably have over a 10
inflation rate and if you think about
that
that puts you in one of the worst
economic situations
in the world top 20 highest inflation
levels in the world
and it's here in the united states it's
crazy and we're getting gaslit
by people who literally take two minutes
to explain to us what transitory means
and they can't figure out how to control
inflation yeah he he talked about
transitory for two and a half minutes
and then he ended with well the
definition is temporary
what now we're gonna get to in a second
why i actually don't think it's jerome
powell's fault
right so like i'm gonna i'm gonna give
my guy a little out here in a minute
but i do think that it's important that
uh we kind of stay on track in terms of
what they're saying
so if we move on jose described
what did people start to call for jerome
powell
to be out what happened yesterday the
wall street journal's editorial board
which is a very esteemed group of people
they're considered
insiders elites they're part of the wall
street journal
it's a group of folks they come together
they write things in probably google
docs
they have editors they use comments they
do the headline
like very professional and this is what
they said
in an op-ed yesterday quote one trait of
the modern fed
is never to take responsibility for
financial and economic problems
the financial panic of 2008 was the
banker's fault
the historically slow expansion after
2009
was the fault of fiscal policy and now
the inflation surge
is due to forces beyond its control if
powell and the fed won't accept
responsibility for the price levels
which is essential to the fed's mission
maybe it's time for a fed chairman who
will
now again this is not me screwing around
on the internet this is not my brother's
texting this to me
this is not a cat photo or laser eyes
or something on a reddit board or
somebody saying this drunk at a bar
this is the wall street journal's
editorial board
writing this that's how serious this has
become
where now we have the mainstream media
starting to
turn on the head of the federal reserve
saying the modern trait
or the trait of the modern fed is to
never take responsibility
for the problems but you have to admit
if you're an outsider looking in that
the fed is more responsible
than probably any other organization
inside of the united states
for both good and bad because they drive
monetary policy and monetary policy is
if not the most one of the most
important aspects of the economy
so if the fed is going to claim that all
the problems all the high inflation is
just supply chain
problems remember we saw aoc say this we
saw joe biden say this
this is a talking point that now is
going to start to permeate
but good for the wall street journal and
their editorial board to call this out
and say
no you are responsible you must take
responsibility that is the job of the
leaders to take responsibility
for high inflation your job is price
stability we do not have price stability
you're failing at your job we do not
have full employment you're failing at
your job
fix it or maybe we need a new fed
chairman now
when you start to think about that
that's a pretty crazy place
12 months ago to think we would be today
but even crazier
is the director of global macro at
fidelity
again a very esteemed person a very well
respected person somebody who most
people would look at and say i would
like to know what that person thinks
about the world
had a tweet thread this morning that is
absolutely epic
and so when we look at what he says here
he starts out with a perspective on
bitcoin claims that it's an aspiring
asset class that looks to be coming of
age
much like gold in the 70s when it was
two also an asset class as a teenager
growing into adulthood
and usually their full potential but
they can also wreck your car so you got
to be careful
and so after bretton woods in the 70s
even though it was a known commodity
gold was extremely volatile
on its way to a 20x return and it
suffered large drawdowns quite regularly
and he describes bitcoin as being a
relative newcomer it's got scarcity and
network effects
and so it makes sense to him that the
upside of bitcoin is greater than gold
as are its drawdowns and that's the
definition
of price discovery remember this is the
director of global macro at fidelity and
then he continues in the thread
and he states below i show bitcoin since
its 2019 low
against gold during the 1970s price
analogs are highly subjective
calls out any sort of bias but clearly
gold's price discovery was highly
volatile much like bitcoin today
by this measure bitcoin's current 50
drawdown could be seen as a bump in the
road
he then goes on to show at the risk of
cherry picking the timing of the above
chart fits
with my supply demand models below both
charts suggest that bitcoin is not done
with its current bullish phase
we now are seeing what i would consider
the unraveling of the well-driven
well-accepted consensus narrative in the
economy
we are seeing the wall street editorial
board call out the federal reserve
chairman and say you're not taking
responsibility for the impact of the
decisions that you and your organization
are making
we're seeing the director of global
macro at fidelity start to talk about
bitcoin being something that is going to
grow into
a full-on asset with more upside than
gold had in the 70s
and this is all with the backdrop of the
federal reserve's balance sheet
continuing to grow to the sky it looks
like a kindergartener
if you said to them draw some lines just
make sure it always goes up into the
right
and when you look at that balance sheet
it hit another all-time high last week
we are now over 8.2 trillion dollars on
the federal reserve balance sheet
we just continue to see look at this it
just continues to go up
there is no stopping the growth of that
fed's
balance sheet there's nothing that
suggests it is going to stop
but it's not just in the united states
either this also is happening around the
world
it's all relative and so if you look at
the ecb's balance sheet for example
you can see that the ecb's balance sheet
is also
growing like a weed it's just looking
for sunlight how do i go up into the
right as fast as possible
and so when you have a dollar being
devalued at a historic rate a balance
sheet hitting an all-time high
the stock market hitting an all-time
high week after week after week
and you have other central banks around
the world also
having balance sheets hit all-time highs
you realize that
it's all one big charade the balance
sheets are all
growing to the sky the currencies are
all being devalued
and it's all a relative rate and if we
go back to
um comments that were made the third
richest man in mexico earlier this year
said that when he grew up it was about
17 mexican pesos to one u.s dollar
today it's 20 000 pesos to one u.s
dollar
now 17 to 20 000 is a big leap
but that's also as the dollar was
devalued as well
and so what we are seeing is again
a rate of change and devaluation that
nobody
can measure i don't have the answers all
i know
is it's way worse than what we're being
told neither does the federal reserve
the treasury the politicians the market
participants etc
we are in uncharted territory and when
you get to uncharted territory
what you need is you need a obsession
with
facts and data in a pursuit of truth
you need people who say we've never been
here before
we need to understand what's going on
and we need to do our best to make sure
that the data that we are using
to make decisions is accurate but that's
not what's happening
we continue to get told a story to keep
markets calm to try to
make people easy and not get upset
or get worried about uncertainty or
chaos in the future
but what we know is that now the
conversation is changing the wall street
journal's
editorial board is calling out the
federal reserve chairman
and people that normally would be
considered
stalwarts of the financial system
like the director of global macro
fidelity are starting to say
i want to go look at something like
bitcoin because i think that that
actually may be a pretty good place to
put some capital
and so i'll leave you with this what is
the solution well
at the same time that all this is
happening today on cnbc
judy shelton who is a former uh nominee
for the federal reserve board
went on television and i don't know her
uh i'm not actually
overly familiar with most of her work
i'm sure she's a nice person very
hard working very well respected within
the finance and
economic world but she said quote
i don't consider myself a hawk or a dove
i'm more
a woodpecker i keep hammering away at
this idea that money is meant to be an
accurate measure it's supposed to convey
price signals my concern about the fed's
actions is that it's muddling that
message
now again that first sentence i don't
consider myself a hawker or a dove
i'm more a woodpecker when you have
a human-led monetary policy
you get in a situation where people are
literally debating are you a hawk a
devil woodpecker or some other animal
instead what we need is we need to move
to a system where
there is zero human interaction and so
when we had the gold standard the gold
standard was actually pretty effective
because the gold standard allowed us to
simply use gold as the underlying
commodity
i don't know where we're headed i don't
know exactly where we are today
but what i do know is that a
programmatic
transparent monetary policy is going to
become
more and more and more attractive to
people around the world
when they compare it in a relative basis
to the chaotic
uncertain world of what will happen next